unbelievable performance last night the
dolphins
trampled the jaguars just like everyone
expected the game unfolded just exactly
no
it did good morning it's pft live peter
king mike florio peacock hello if you're
watching us live series xm211 nbcsn on
the rear at 9am eastern sky sports 7
o'clock uk and ireland time week 3
preview but week 3 thursday night
football review and
it was a rewind for ryan fitzpatrick it
was fitzpatrick at his best peter equal
parts passer and fullback at one point
last night i think joe buck compared him
to larry zonka
and that wasn't a stretch the way the
guy was running the football how shocked
were you by what we saw from fitzpatrick
and the dolphins last night
you said it right at the top
you know i i really think there are
times when ryan fitzpatrick plays that
you look at it and you say
this guy is a playoff quarterback
uh and there are other times where you
say oh my god tua can't get ready fast
enough
but i think mike you know there's two
big lessons out of this game last night
number one
the miami dolphins saved their season
and that miami dolphins team
can be a contender
now will they be that way every week
does it help to play jacksonville on a
short week
apparently
uh
but you know i think the one other thing
to think about with that game last night
is
i i kept thinking
now
haven't there started to be some noises
the gardner minshew is the franchise
quarterback and the jaguars don't need a
quarterback and they're fine with
minshew
and
when he overthrew i think it was uh
geez i'm trying to remember he overthrew
i think chris conley by about eight
yards when he was wide open running into
the end zone wide open
and i just said you know
maybe we shouldn't be so fast to say
that uh if the jaguars are picking first
that they shouldn't take uh
uh trevor lawrence so i don't know those
are my two takeaways and and by the way
does ryan fitzpatrick have some fun
playing football
i mean he's got some fun playing
football
he and he went to harvard if you haven't
heard that
yeah he's now beating the jaguars
on six different teams
ryan
he's now beating the jaguars six
different teams six different uniforms
it's now easier to list the teams that
ryan fitzpatrick hasn't played for than
the ones that he has played for but he's
back in that that vibe that we saw a
couple of years ago when jameis winston
was suspended and he was the tampa bay
buccaneers quarterback and and he does
ride that wave
and and it all works
and it works incredibly well until the
moment that it doesn't and that's the
thing with ryan fitzpatrick he will from
time to time have the planets line up
and everything works and he's a playoff
caliber quarterback and when you buy in
that's when it happens see we're setting
the stage for a week four meltdown by
ryan fitzpatrick by praising him this
much because the moment we buy in
is the moment that it goes off the rails
and i can't remember another quarterback
who performs like that
where there are these huge swings and
just when you think he's finally got it
all figured out
it goes in the other direction which is
just amazing to me here are some of his
teammates though praising ryan
fitzpatrick for a great performance that
we saw on thursday night against
jacksonville
fitz's at his mind he's 38 years old and
still you know playing this game like
he's 23
but you know to have him as you know our
leader and you know you just see the the
fun that he has and
um you know i mean after after i scored
my touchdown you know we just came off
the sideline just started yelling and
screaming and chest pumping i mean it's
just it's so fun to play with him um you
know whether it's those plays like like
you're talking about where you know he
refuses to slide and all that kind of
stuff uh or it's the the fun that he has
or the experience that he shows to the
guys around him
you know whatever it is it's always
great you know playing with him coming
into a game thursday night game like
this he's always just kind of laughing
and joking uh trying to make sure
everybody's just
honed in and just not too amped up not
too low just hey let's this is the game
we played since
we were little kids like at the end of
the day this is the game we play and
this is what we're here for we're here
to ball out how he conducts the huddle
how he conducts this offense
really reflects on you know how we can
perform
i think it's
like we did a good job tonight with it
you know i've been making the argument
recently peter we've seen what joe
burrow the first overall pick in the
draft can do so far so good we saw what
justin herbert the sixth overall pick in
the draft can do unexpectedly last
weekend against kansas city so far so
good let's see what tuatanga viloa the
fifth overall pick of the dolphins can
do throw him into the fray let's go
let's see what he has
and ryan fitzpatrick is holding that off
there's no way you can flip
from what we saw last night to tua
because you can't keep that guy on the
bench because as of right now the
absolute best that tua could do if
everything fell his way would be to
replicate what we saw from ryan
fitzpatrick
yeah and i think it's going to be very
interesting to watch especially mike
over the next two weeks okay
because the miami dolphins have seattle
at home
and then they go to san francisco and
again san francisco is about 55 of san
francisco right now because of all the
injuries but
these are two really good
uh
have good parts
of a team
but
i kind of am going to be fascinated by
seattle making that long trip
and playing against a team that is
competent offensively
and woke up on defense last night
especially because when you look at
seattle right now seattle's been gashed
some so that's not the impossible dream
for miami to give seattle a really good
game next week and then hey the 49ers
we'll see i don't know who's going to be
on the field for him but
i definitely think you're right you
can't switch to tua now
and you know the thing is i said this
yesterday we're getting closer and
closer to that point in the season that
i call correction sunday where we think
we know we think we understand we think
we have it all figured out and then
results happen
that that make us say what the hell were
we thinking and last night's game was a
warning shot in that regard the
desperation that the dolphins had at oh
and too and the fact that they played
the patriots and the bills pretty close
right they didn't get blown off the
field they didn't get embarrassed maybe
that should have told us that they were
in a position to get a win and and this
was one of those you got to get your
wins when you can this is a win you got
to get because you may lose the next two
and oh and three becomes oh and five and
then you got a real problem if you're
the miami dolphins then it's last year
all over again where they had to dig out
of that hole and we know what this
team's capable of because they dug out
of that hole last year i guess that's
the key if they could get off to a
little bit faster start this year and
finish the way they did last year and
they've got that back-to-back games
against the jets week 10 week 12 with a
buy in between that's a couple of wins
check those off this is a team that with
seven playoff spots this is a team that
could make things interesting if they
can play like they played last night
you're right mike but and again you
don't want to go down too much of a
rabbit hole looking at the schedule
but look at the last month of the season
you know kansas city new england vegas
and and at buffalo
so that that's
you know even if they're in good shape
on their schedule with four games to go
even if they're let's just say six and
six
with four games to go that is still
going to be a bataan death march to uh
uh to a playoff berth so
you know as as crazy as it sounds i mean
miami has got to be over 500 after they
have that game against cincinnati i
think when is it yeah early december so
those are the kind of things i think
when you look at miami long term
there can't be many more sacrificial
games
for miami coming up this year
and and i don't want to go too far down
the rabbit hole of the realities of
scheduling in the nfl but when you now
have four playoff spots to go to
division winners and three that go to
wild cards where you cross division
lines that spin of the wheel every year
that gets you
one division in its entirety in your own
conference and one division in its
entirety in the other conference if
you're an afc east this afc east team
this year and you have designs on
getting a wild card berth and half your
schedule is against the afc west and the
nfc west
that that's an uphill climb for
everybody and that this is one of the
things that i think as as we see how it
shakes out
a few years with this seven teams per
conference there's going to be a focus
on this idea of how fair is it to make
half your schedule hinge on just
whatever year it is for you to play all
the teams of this division and all the
teams of that division because it does
make it hard for the dolphins the bills
the patriots the jets whichever team
doesn't win the division they've got
some tough tough games that get compared
across division lines to see who gets
those three wild card births brian
flores in year number two is head coach
of the miami dolphins doing what he can
to turn around a franchise that has been
more dysfunctional than not over the
past 40 years or so here's flores
talking about how it's all starting to
pay off given all the work that they've
been putting in
you know it's always
important to
you know when you work hard for
something and you you
see the fruits of that labor like i just
mentioned it's it's it's a good thing
hopefully it builds confidence but
um
we've gotta we gotta continue to work
the way we've been working
and continue to grow
as a team as a staff
and you know
it feels good to win that's that's
that's
that's
it definitely feels good to win
you know and here's the key peter and i
think this is a critical component for
any of the coaches who come from the
bill belichick tree guys who have been
with him for years who go out on their
own they bring a different attitude they
bring a different requirement it's zero
funds sir as uh we heard and remember
the titans which came out 20 years ago i
think yesterday
you have to win to get your guys to buy
in
at some point they have to see that this
works and if it doesn't work they're
eventually going to say hey look i'm i'm
okay with zero funds sir if we win but
if we're still gonna suck i'd rather
have fun while we suck and and that may
be the difference between matt patricia
and detroit and brian flores in miami
once they start to see
that it can pay off
then they say okay we get it we
understand we can sign up for zero funds
sir
yeah i think you're right mike but i
also think that
you know patricia has more of a track
record he's sort of on the edge of an
abyss right now
um
you know who who knows whether he's even
going to make it through this full
season
um and
you know whereas flores i think
the the end of last year you know having
a better record than new england after
halloween i think
really buys him time and and quite
honestly buys him credibility in his
locker room
because those guys last year midway
through the season whatever they were 0
and 7
um midway through the season those guys
started to see that even though their
record wasn't very good you know they
played some pretty darn good games the
game they played at pittsburgh on monday
night
they they had some they had some good
games last year and so i guess the way i
look at the miami situation is
their arrow is pointing
uh definitely you know maybe not this
way but at least this way a little bit
and you know in detroit
i
you know i i don't know i don't see much
of a way out of this
you know especially if matthew stafford
is not
a 5500 yard quarterback this year or
something i mean he he's gonna have to
really really
uh make that team score 30 32
points a game down the stretch in my
opinion for them to win because their
defense just isn't good enough
we know that matthew stafford is the
best things the line the lions have
going for them what's the best thing
that dolphins have going for them
i think
the the fact that
they see
that what brian flores is doing is
working
and just keep doing it okay even when uh
you have some bad losses even when you
open up with a real clunker to the
patriots and score 11 points
you know against the team that's totally
rebuilding its defense basically or it's
at least you know it's linebacking core
and
you know don't go crazy when that
happens because when you're building
something
uh
you know it's going to take time
and and the other thing i think
they have that you can really hang your
hat on
is a trust
a trust in this system that flores has
put in a trust in the personnel things
that chris greer has done as general
manager and and look you know mike last
year early in the season that locker
room was very skeptical
you know after getting rid of minka
fitzpatrick after getting rid of laramie
tunsil after getting rid of kenny stills
but now you look at it you say hey
listen we've got some good young players
in those positions
and you know you're starting to see him
and gaseki
is not a rookie or anything like that
but he's a really good young player one
of the best young tight ends in football
and those are the kind of people you
start seeing
on this team and so you have a trust in
the system and say we're going to be
okay
you know last year gardner minshew was
viewed as sort of a poor man's baker
mayfield early this year maybe baker
mayfield is a poor man's gardener mint
shoe but last night it was rough for
gardner minshew peter as you mentioned
earlier the overthrow i think part of
the problem was every drop back he had
someone in his face i mean if you're not
going to give a guy any blocking
whatsoever it's kind of hard to run the
offense they've got something special in
james robinson undrafted from illinois
state he's got burst he's got that
factor you can just tell he belongs he
delivers punishment he keeps going he
holds on to the football he can catch it
he can run it he scored two touchdowns
last night he's got it
without d.j shark last night who was
ultimately scratched with chest and back
injuries that made it harder for minshew
but you know peter look i i still
believe in minshu
i just think that he needs to play in a
game where there aren't constantly guys
from the front seven everywhere he goes
well i would agree mike but
you know and i hate to be
belichicki in here but it is what it is
you know russell wilson survives with
guys in his face
and again i'm not i'm not
comparing these two guys but
you know when you're a quarterback in
the nfl you've got to deal with what you
have
and russell wilson deals with it fine he
got hit hard on three of his five
touchdown releases on sunday against the
patriots and gardner minshew last night
really struggled with pressure really
struggled
uh on the roll out he made a really bad
read and it should have been intercepted
there were just too many dolphins around
the ball you know so i guess i look at
it and say i like minshu too
but too many performances like that last
night
and uh you know all the jorts are going
to disappear and the orange clemson
jerseys are going to appear in the crowd
with trevor lawrence's number on it
i still think the jaguars have a long
way to go before they're in contention
for trevor lawrence because there are
some pretty bad because of the nfl right
now because of the jets and because of
the vikings the vikings are going to
give the jets a run for their money by
the time it's all said
if you watched have you watched stop
have you watched the games have you no i
have not a king but no okay but hey
listen you know what cousins is trust me
yeah hey mike kirk cuz is going to throw
for 380 this week you know four
touchdowns no interceptions because
that's who he is yeah you know one week
i think that's one of the big problems
one of the best they're not winning
mike they're not winning three games
they're not winning three games
who the vikings the vikings yeah
i i they're not going to be in
contention for the first pick in the
draft
yeah well we'll we'll see we'll see how
that plays out and i don't know the
jaguars are only going to win three
games i thought when you said the
vikings aren't going to win three games
i don't need to in 14. that's what i
thought you meant now i'm ready to go
under three wins for the vikings based
on what i've seen so far hey how about
this last because you're a fan
uh no i'm a realist we saw for the
second time so far this season a player
get ejected for contact with an official
and cam robinson i don't know what he
was thinking
well but here's the thing he's at the
bottom of the pile and he's trying to
get the football and and i thought they
ejected him for the first one where you
see him push the arm that's kind of
draped over the top of his helmet
but then he's got a guy on top of him
who's in black and white stripes and he
pushes him away and that's where he
crossed the line the first one i'd give
him the second one it's like okay i
understand why they ejected the guy yeah
when you see those black and white
stripes in your face you can't start
flailing your arms and kicking your feet
you know what i didn't see in that
though i mean
and again
i'm not positive what exactly happened
but i would really like to know i guess
we could have to do a supruder film of
that tape but what i would really like
to know is was he
was he looking
what he saw did he see the ref
and did he actually push the ref knowing
it was the ref that's what i would like
to know
and you know here's the other side of it
too if they're going to get into the
fray like that there's a certain amount
of incidental contact jostling exactly
yeah yeah if if there's if there's a
group of guys
and they're in that that scrum and you
decide you're going to physically insert
yourself into the middle of it and then
you're going to start ejecting guys for
contacting you once you've inserted
yourself into the missing you've
converted me already because i thought
hey he's the guy's right there he's on
top of him it's clearly official that's
the point where you have to stop but
he's in that get off me mode i mean god
only knows what was going on at the
bottom of that pile god only knows what
golf dolphins players were grabbing and
twisting at the bottom of the pile we've
heard the stories over the years you get
to a point where you just want to get
the hell out of there and uh yeah if
you're the official and you're going to
jump on top of that then you're you're
assuming the risk of of god forbid
getting your arms shoved away by a
player who's trying to escape the pile
um meanwhile peter i think uh ryan
fitzpatrick may have raided your closet
after the game last night do we have the
photo he had on i think that was that
yours
those are my pants those are my pants